les gens en ont assez assez des excès du
président du conseil exécutif de la ctm
on a toujours connu avec un tempérament
excessif tout le monde relativisait
jusqu alors ses propos mais là
maintenant ça prend une dimension qui
est devenu insupportable et c'est
d'autant plus insupportable que en
réalité il est soutenu dans dans ce
genre de propos par d'autres élus que je
trouve encore plus coupable que lui et
tout le monde tout le monde a constaté
qu'il y avait une sorte de syndrome
obsessionnel au niveau de l'exécutif
il doit répondre à l'autre le vent divin
des semaines en jeudi ce qui est la
réalité ils voient des complots partout
bon donc je pense que ça suffit car il
s'agit du personnage politique qui
détient le plus de pouvoirs à la
martinique les militants et adm sont
outrés outré des attaques d'abord dans
leurs sociétés régionales fait l'objet
sont indignés et ils me disent que il
faut maintenant que l'on marque une
sorte de 2,2 d'arrêt qu' il y a une
limite
une sorte de deux lignes rouges qui est
maintenant à tête et qu'il ne faut pas
laisser dépasser